i don't think it's a surprise after the
uh allegations made by mr cummings last
night it was uh inevitable really that
he would be interviewed uh he has
confirmed to sky news that he's going to
be interviewed and
as a cabinet office source has told us
if we reach the end of the investigation
the inquiry hasn't spoken to dominic
cummings eyebrows would be raised well i
think that's an understatement uh that
would be extraordinary given the
allegations he made last night let me
just remind you what he said last night
uh he said uh that uh
that
that
he warned mr reynolds that's martin
reynolds the principal for private
secretary who wrote the now notorious
bring your own booze email about the
party or the event on the 20th of may
2020 broke the rules and he raised his
concerns directly with the pm i said to
the pm something like martin's invited
the building to a drinks party this is
what i'm talking about you've got to
grip this mad house the pm waved it
aside and he said um
the
the events of the 20th of may and alone
never mind the string of other events
mean the pm
lied to parliament about parties not
only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath this is what happened well
the prime minister has denied that
version of events in that long interview
with beth rigby
he looked stressed he looked worn out
big bags black circles under his eyes
and close to tears particularly during
the questioning about uh the uh about
the party uh uh on the eve of prince
philip's funeral when the queen sat and
mourned alone at windsor castle pm has a
chance to fight back at uh prime
minister's questions tomorrow